well as you can imagine if we have
something you need for life and the
demand is going like that and the supply
is going like that until they're
crossing no surprise you get private
sector interest coming in and saying
well there's gold in that there in them
there hills right there's gold in that
blue I call it to the gold there's gold
in that water and so from every facet of
water from the delivery of water to your
home or the treatment of wastewater to
bottled water to now these great big
desalination plants water recycling even
getting into nanotechnology cloud
seeding so one village in China steals
the rain before it gets to the next we
are beginning to see what I call a
corporate cartel around water which is
that water is beginning to be claimed
and owned by private sector interest
before you know even before it's out of
the ground almost and I see it I think
we can we can compare it to energy
companies so that when I drop a new drop
of our new find of gas or oil is
discovered it's owned and spoken for by
a corporation before it's even out of
the ground I worry about this very much
because as as corporations control more
and more about water of the water in the
world they're going to be able to charge
exorbitant prices already charging
exorbitant prices for bottled water if
you can't afford it to heck with you
right and so what's happening is that
water is going to be taken out of the
the price range of millions and millions
of people already in the third world
millions of people haven't got access to
water that who would have access to
water if they could buy it big companies
like Suez and Veolia have been forced on
the global South countries by the world
bank and they come in and they run these
water systems on a for-profit basis sure
there's water but if you can't pay for
it they turn your tap off they turn the
meter off and that's beginning to happen
here to a few years ago in Detroit the
the Water Authority there turned the
water systems off to 42,000
families mostly African Americans older
people poor people who couldn't pay
their water bills because the water
bills were jacked up and then they
turned around and they sent social
services in it took the kids away if
they had small children in the house
because they couldn't provide water to
the kids right so it was a really a
really serious thing and you're going to
hear more of that in the quote the north
of global north and north america and
europe and so on where we have lots of
poor people and even a middle class is
going to have trouble paying water bills
when they're jacked up three times with
or four times what they are now water is
probably going to have to reflect more
of its real value in terms of we
probably are going to have to charge but
we need to provide a certain basic
amount of water for human needs every
day to people free of charge and what's
happening in the developing world is
that they haven't been doing it that way
they you know if they say maybe a tiny
bit but it's not enough to live on and
so people are in crisis everywhere so
the corporate that and then the end then
there's bottled water in bottled water
last year we put something like 50
billion litres of water in plastic
around the world creating just mountains
of plastic garbage using more fossil
fuels more energy of course you know
which which contributes to the whole
global warming phenomenon and it's it's
another way of privatizing water because
if you say well I'm going to not going
to trust tap water anymore and that's
foolish because North America your tap
water is safer than bottled water it's
more regulated than bottled water but if
you say oh I don't trust it anymore so
i'm going to use bottled water then
you're then you're basically saying i
don't care what comes out of the tap so
i'm not going to pay taxes to have the
infrastructure repaired so that the
water coming out of the tap is safe
because i don't care because i'm not
drinking that stuff anymore so it's a
disconnect from the public tab and the
more we disconnect the more some people
will have bottled water they buy and
other people will have a system that may
be allowed to deteriorate because those
people buying bottled water for richer
and probably more powerful don't care
anymore so it's a really vicious cycle
we have to care what comes out of the
tap not just for us but for our
neighbors for people we even don't know
because public hell
is connected to public water which is
why we got public water in the first
place New York had private water at one
point and it was such a disaster this
was a century ago it was such a disaster
that they the government took it over
and said we will run it as a public
service and the reason was not so
altruistic that everybody has the right
although some people believed and still
believe that I believe that but it was
also that the only way to fight the
public diseases was diphtheria and these
kind of things was with clean water for
everybody and so if you had that
stability in that health that gave you
the economic basis to build your
resources and to build up a domestic
economy and so clean water was a very
important found a clean public water was
an important foundation of our wealth in
the north and we need to remember that
it's if there's a reason that you have
good clean water for everybody just like
I think there should be a reason to have
good health care for everybody because
it benefits the whole society and it's
expensive when people get sick from
dirty water
you